to stop russian bombs falling on their
cities
please close the sky
for you crying
help us
we are alone
a desperate plea from the ukrainian
people
something that u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken on his visit to poland
made clear will not happen
a 45-minute meeting with ukraine's
foreign minister at the border a public
show of support at his country's darkest
hour the
entire world
stands with ukraine
uh just as i'm standing here
in ukraine
with my friend
my colleague jimmy chuckleeva the
foreign minister of ukraine
if they continue to provide us
with necessary weapons
the price will be
lower
this will save many lives in ukraine
many houses
many children will be born many
sufferings will be avoided
despite the symbolic visit direct
american military help something that
could risk triggering a global conflict
stops at the polish border
volunteers say the anxiety uncertainty
frustration and sadness of refugees at
the often chaotic medical border
crossing must be seen to be understood
having skipped it on his tour blinken
they say may struggle to comprehend the
level of help ukraine needs
i mean professing solidarity is one
thing and acting and actually doing
something is another thing i can say a
lot of words too but it doesn't mean
anything if i don't do anything with my
hands i am not present here i don't see
it in my with my eyes
millions more could soon be making their
way on the refugee trail
short of direct military intervention by
anyone it will continue to be a growing
challenge for ukrainian forces to stop
the russian advance let alone push it
back what we have been seeing here at
the medical border crossing is more and
more medics and volunteer fighters with
military gear with medical supplies
coming to this border crossing crossing
into ukraine and then making their way
to the front line
ukrainians know they are isolated and
largely alone in this fight
waiting for help from the outside world
fighter jets attack aircraft air defense
systems the kind of help they need to
stop russia over running their country
the kind of help that is not coming
zain basravi al-jazeera medical border
crossing eastern poland